quelle audience pour le retour de matt
singer le lancement a été difficile pour
ma singer samedi soir puisqu'ils ont
perdu presque 2 millions téléspectateurs
par rapport au lancement de l'an dernier
alors que le total sa demi sachet qui
lui + 7 % que téléspectateurs par
rapport à un samedi normal à cause du
couvre feu donc à 17% en plus et +23 %
de 25,49 sur l'ensemble du total télé ça
n'a pas profité à ma singer 4 8 millions
de téléspectateurs
il avait fait 6 6 millions lors du
lancement la saison 1 et il avait fait
32 5% et là ils ont fait 24 3 alors ça
reste des scores honorables mais c'est
vrai que c'est c'est compliqué et c'est
vrai que c'est une émission je vous le
dis à l'étranger
la première saison avait cartonné et
plus ça va plus les saisons baisse et
pas seulement sur la france sachez le
dans tous les pays où cette émission a
été vendu c'est de pire en pire les
audiences et on comprend parce que c'est
vrai qu'à première fois c est génial
la deuxième fois c'est toujours un peu
génial et la première fois ci ça va
commencer à nous péter les noisettes
alors et intuition beaucoup de monde
s'est posé
c'est quoi le public ne portait pas de
masque beaucoup d'internautes se sont
posé la question et ont été un peu
choqué en voyant les images sur toutes
les missions ont été tournées en juillet
donc en période de covile alors on a les
images et je vais vous répondre après
regarde
[Musique]
les enquêteurs est ce que vous avez un
dernier projet n'est comparable que
d'autres où je rejoigne sa tanière oui
alors vous dire le tournage a eu lieu au
mois de juillet deux jours par semaine
et le décret sur les masques
obligatoires hu a eu en lieu en lieu
clos a été publié le 18 juillet au
journal officiel ils ont donc bien
respecté les règles sachez le la
production et tf1 ou bien respecté les
règles au niveau des masses qu'il n'y a
aucun problème puisque le public sur un
masque et lors des prochains épisodes
vous nous confirmez oui exactement
voilà donc voilà donc tout a été bien
respecté je vous dis voilà tout va bien
le casting at il été démasqué main
certains noms circulent déjà sur twitter
une prestation qui a fait beaucoup
parler c'est celle des perroquets alors
tout le monde sur les réseaux sociaux on
est sûr il s'agit d'el hamdaoui se situe
mots avec des manteaux ouais parce que
le costume du perroquet follow santé
[Rires]
[Musique]
bonjour nous sommes ravis arrive quand
on chante sur scène
moi la télé on ne sent pas qu'en
français il faut savoir s'ouvrir à
l'international
rien n'est loin dans le temps la musique
comme les modes tout est cyclique
nous
la coupable
m
et cela pour des moutons
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai c'est pas si simple que
ça peut être à part les bogdanoff en
tout cas on les embrasse si les
bogdanoff sont dans les perroquets et 10
qui chante et qui chante ans dans le
pays donc c'est monsieur sur dans la
boîte en laponie ils ont fait un tube
avec moi ils sont
alors frédéric vichot contient dans
matzinger vous étiez caché sous le
costume de la bouche va revoir votre
prestation et votre élimination
vous avez chanté sur fuck you de lily
allen avait les téléspectateurs
attendent bien sûr ce que vous pensez de
masse singer autour de la table regardez
la prestation de frais des frais d une
fois on aura payé guérison de dire que
j'ai une trop grande bouche
[Musique]
eric dane
[Applaudissements]
triste incroyable
pourquoi accepter cette aventure et bien
des périodes improbable on fait des
choses a parfois un tchador voilà la
laisse la réponse est folle
c'est c'est quoi c'est moi paix pendant
le continent j'étais un peu en pyjama et
ne peut pas été travaillée des chansons
à casa rangèrent de johnny c'était à
travailler aux machines la bouche on a
on a décidé à singer offredo mais moi
aussi mais c'est vrai parce que vous
êtes quand même je vous dis est une
actrice quand même il n'y a pas de quand
même faire que moi je suis une artiste
ah oui c'est ça chantait j'adore me
déguiser j'adore et la bouche elle a
tout un tas elle a une histoire vous
êtes pas dit mais non je vais me
retrouver avec un casting
bon c'est pas l'année dernière j'en ai
rien à [ __ ] mathis et bondir sa moi
j'ai commencé à la télé avec la minute
blonde où elle m'a dit tu ne seras
jamais de cinéma après j'ai fait du
cinéma tu fais de la comédie trash
diamètre cinéma d'auteur après j'étais
du cinéma d'auteur avec moi mais là le
cinéma d'auteur dit tu fais de la pub il
ya toujours un truc donc même si je dis
ça fait 20 ans que je tourne j'ai la
carte
j'aimerais te blanche je peux faire ce
que je veux me déguiser chanter alors
que pendant le confinement
j'étais en manque de caméra permettra de
travail dgt envie d' envoi de souci là
évidemment il ya toujours la vérité
j'ai passé la roja qui se sont acquis ce
soit sur ces normalement on comprend
tout à fait et g mais voilà dans
laquelle j'ai fait le trait magnifique
travaux mais voilà comment des
promotions ne se tue pas le droit de
dire c'est contracture à peu près bon on
est à peu près ici c'est en fait
personne n'est payé pareil d'accord ça
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont dit ils
ont fait sortir frédérique bel et laure
manoudou avoir son élimination pas ce
que c'était cette hausse est le plus
classe dans le casting parce que je
crois qu'ils ont une star internationale
je sais que tu sais un bon paquet
suspect qui s'est écrit moi j'ai vu
personne ici n'ont pas pas le dire parce
qu'on veut pas brûler pas le regarder
leur match
[Musique]
la première personnalité à ce débat ce
qu'est ce soir
c'est le loup
[Applaudissements]
démasquage
[Musique]
c'est long
[Applaudissements]
laure manaudou la plus grande nageuse
française triple championne olympique
mais ces foules
alors les cherry on va vous avez dire ce
que vous pensez de ma singer moi la
vérité j'aime beaucoup camille et
camille et j'adore le jury c'est tous
des potes en fait j'ai que des potes
pour cette émission mais l'émission je
la comprends pas en quoi sa levée de
fonds mais ça ne m'intéresse pas du tout
je vous dis la vérité je comprends pas
comment on peut s'intéresser hamas
singer en fait voir des nez des costumes
en train de shooter j'ai l'impression de
talent à domicile had six essais
inscrits je sais pas peut-être je suis
passe à côté - et peut-être que t'es pas
j'ai pas construit et des enfants
adorent mais j'y vais parce que mes
nièces et là c'est lorsque leur émission
préférée
et si on prend en compte en date à
danser mais j'étais chez mon boucher a
tenté de danse et c'est intéressant
c'est que c'est choquant et dont
l'effectif est chaud oui jugé jean
michel nouaille moi je pèse mes mots
mais honnêtement je préférais avoir le
ver solitaire qui nous regardent tout
mais quel est l'intérêt et je suis assez
bon fredrik parce que je pense que la
faible largeur elle est bien là son
choix fait par égard pour l'âge à
laquelle ça vous quel est l'intérêt de
regarder des gens qui sont venus en
famille les gens qu'on ne reconnaît pas
comme ils sont pas on dirait que ce
s'agisse pas bon dont on ne reconnaît
pas la voix et tout ça par des indices
est en fait à la fin les gens ils se
lèvent pour applaudir un pool peu
alors est-ce que vous rappeler quel
était le problème
lors de l'émission la première fois oui
alors tout le monde charrier l'émission
à ce que les enquêteurs proposer des
stars de louvain michelle obama et
gelabale officiel obama voilà senna
maison christophe cochard cette saison
je crois qu'ils ont compris
c'est dire je pense peut-être à nicolas
sarkozy parce que voilà il est avec ses
fans il a côtoyé des gens on en sais pas
moi c'est vraiment tout est vraiment
franck dubosc et moi je pense très fort
à marc lavoine pascal anne pascale omar
sy michel hazanavicius
je pense à guillaume canet moi je suis
dans 77 donc je pense à bernard minet
avec vincent lagaf' anthony dupray et
armelle marlène jobert patrick jouvet
laurent ournac la route
lola du bing et ils sont libres
malgré ces lévriers réinvente du jury
qui m'a dit je vais il est bien question
de mais là je ne sais pas ce qui me gêne
beaucoup sais que j'ai encore une fois
l'impression qu'on dupes les gens alors
je sais pas si frédéric naud relâchez
pas là mais bon à quel niveau alors je
vais vous le dire quand le les membres
du jury annonce les noms comme par
hasard is it laure manaudou très vite et
vous frédérique bel kev adams vous cite
à la fin je voudrais rajouter frédérique
bel
ou alors selon mes informations c'est
quand même très prévu à l'avant ce qu'on
fait
vous faites un tout petit peu semblant à
la fin en lâche lui déçu de sortir mais
selon mes informations il ya des
disponibilités des uns et des autres
c'est un peu encore une fois comme sur
certaines émissions de tf1 c'est à dire
qu'en fonction du calendrier des uns et
des autres on les fait sortir au bout
d'une ou de deux émissions saviez pas
les dommages sont blancs salaire passe
après les ricains on aurait recommencé
le vote le vote
ouais y'a le bas du bling du jury ouais
le public est dans la bonne voie si je
vais voter le public pour faire sortir à
tout
voilà donc pour moi c'est organisé pour
la personne qui a la plus grosse
poitrine vrai problème c'est que déjà on
ne veut pas on n'est pas impliqué dans
l'émission mais assez chaud pour les
mécréants matelas un pool points et on
peut même pas intervenir sur une chose
dont tout est fait par avance et cd vous
avez pas intéressant en est on